Camila Cabello debut solo single is  finally here I gave you all of me here  from the heartbreak ballad I have  questions  [Music]  - Camila showing off her sexy side in  the upbeat tunes of crying in the club  [Music]  singers new album the hurting the  healing the loving seems promising  following her exit from fifth harmony  and here's what et knows so crying in  the club I collaborated with SIA which  was really cool  Charli XCX I did a couple songs with her  Pharrell I did a song with him the song  was also produced by Benny Blanco who is  behind hits from ed Sheeran and Katy  Perry and so cool and the catchy song  will soon make it to the big stage as  Camila gets ready for her debut live  performance of crying in the club at the  2017 Billboard Music Awards in Vegas  [Music]  it's here sir - SS  [Music]